[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la canne
c'est un truc de vieux
c'est vrai c'est un accessoire de
soutien c'est un accessoire désuet le
port de la canne est d'aucune idée pour
moi qui suis en mes verte années c'est
absurde porter la canne en 2022
mais aux yeux d'un homme du début du
siècle dernier il y a bien plus absurde
que cela
il y a les paroles que je viens de tenir
en effet à l'âge d'or de la canne entre
19 entre 1830 et 1914 aucun gentilhomme
n'aurait songé à sortir sans
l'indispensable accessoire
ce n'écoute tournant des années 50 que
la canne sera associée à la vieillesse
mais alors pourquoi la canne a-t-elle
disparu dans la garde-robe du
gentilhomme qu'est-ce qui a fait que cet
accessoire autrefois aussi indispensable
que le chapeau ou les chaussures est
tombé en désuétude
ça traverse cette interrogation que je
m'efforcer en quelques minutes de vous
raconter mon histoire qui m'a mené à
cette relation si particulière que
j'entretiens avec la canne que je
fabrique que je vends que je porte et
que j'essaie d'en bien que mal de
remettre au Pinnacle
pour cela il faut remonter à 2020 avant
le confinement je me suis dit couvert
une passion pour le travail du bois mais
j'étais constamment frustré par le
manque de temps et la fatigue d'une
journée de cours
et si le confinement a tous plus ou
moins changé la vie de tout le monde
il fut pour moi une véritable bouffée
d'air pur un rêve éveillé j'étais
affranchi des contraintes de temps je
n'avais plus l'école pour me pomper
toute mon énergie et autant vous dire
que les cours en ligne c'était loin
d'être ma priorité
j'ai donc pu développer mon atelier et
commencer à vendre quelques créations
mais hélas toutes les belles histoires
ont une fin en septembre 2020 après 5
mois et demi sans école à travailler
librement
il a fallu rentrer au lycée
le contenu des cours ne m'intéressait
vraiment pas et je savais que ce que je
voulais faire c'était rentré chez moi
aller dans mon atelier pour expérimenter
de nouvelles techniques et développer
mes compétences
j'étais donc absent à au moins la moitié
des cours et je savais que de toute
façon ça n'allait pas continuer ainsi
pendant trois ans
et puis à la rentrée des premières
petites vacances j'ai eu un blocage je
ne pouvais pas y aller c'était
impossible ça ne pouvait pas continuer
j'ai donc basculé dans la case des
personnes déscolariser alors le terme
d'escolarisé d'ailleurs qu'un adjectif
qui nous qualifie sur ce qu'on n'est pas
au lieu de prendre en compte ce qu'on
est bref
[Applaudissements]
une fois des scolarisés j'ai donc eu
beaucoup plus de temps c'est là que je
décide de créer mon premier business
j'ai trouvé dans la rue un pied de un
ancien pietement de machine à coudre à
[ __ ] j'ai fixé dessus une planche avec
des roulements qui entraîne un axe et
une meule
et à 14 ans j'ai fabriqué un Touré à
meuler avec des matériaux de
récupération trouver dans la rue
[Applaudissements]
je suis ensuite allé
pardonnez-moi
je suis ensuite allé voir le plastique
du marché local et il a accepté que je
me mette sur le côté pour affûter les
couteaux des passants en un mois j'ai
fait 500 euros en travaillant 4 heures
par semaine j'avais beaucoup de demandes
il n'y avait zéro offre c'est donc moi
qui fixer les prix
c'était merveilleux je pouvais
rencontrer des gens échanger leur rendre
service voir le sourire des personnes
âgées heureuses de pouvoir enfin se
servir du couteau familial hérité qui ne
coupait plus malheureusement
et surtout gagner de l'argent à la
mesure du service rendu était une
gratification extraordinaire je n'avais
jamais connu ça
mais malheureusement encore une fois
toutes les bonnes choses ont une fin
faut savoir que ce que j'ai fait en
France c'est interdit
pourriez me dire il y a pas de raison je
viens je rends service aux gens ils
accède de me payer alors certes c'est
pas officiel mais ça reste honnête
et puis il y a des gens bizarres qui
sont venus et qui ont commencé à me
parler de juridiction de Kbis de siret
un lexique un peu bizarre digne d'une
secte un peu étrange
et puis un jour la police arrivait je
vous épargne les détails mais disons que
la déscolarisation mais il a une
activité de délinquance ça n'a pas
vraiment plu au service sociaux mais
franchement je les plains parce qu'avec
moi ils avaient l'air franchement perdu
je m'exprimais correctement il avait pas
d'histoire de drogue pas de violence
familiale juste un jeune de 15 ans qui
veut travailler et qui ne pouvait pas
autant vous dire qu'ils étaient
complètement déboussolés il n'avait
jamais eu à faire un tel cas
suite à cet épisode tumultueux j'ai
discuté avec quelqu'un qui souhaitait
ouvrir dans sa maison un marché aux
artisans et il était suffisamment ouvert
d'esprit pour ne pas me parler de règles
de juridiction de normes ce genre de
choses j'ai donc pu continuer pendant à
peu près maintenant un an mon activité
d'affûtage sans problème
depuis cet événement j'ai décidé
d'éloigner le plus possible de mon cerf
professionnel les gens qui passent leur
temps à me parler des règles
je les appelle les jurides cerveau
gauche juristes parce qu'ils n'ont que
la loi en tête cerveau gauche parce que
c'est le cerveau rationnel ça leur coupe
toute créativité à croire que leur
cerveau droit n'est pas irrigué
ce sont des gens qui sont fondament
ferme fondamentalement fermés d'esprit
et pas prêt au changement
pour moi les règles ne suffisent pas
pour créer il faut sortir du cadre qui
existe déjà pour moi les règles c'est
une ressource au même titre que l'argent
ou le temps par exemple les règles nous
guident et nous donne à peu près le
chemin à suivre ça peut être quelque
chose que l'on risque pour une
plus-value future ou quelque chose que
l'on garde précieusement dans un coffre
pour moi l'éthique personnelle a plus si
ce n'est autant si ce n'est plus de
valeur que la loi parce que l'État n'a
pas le monopole de l'éthique alors il
s'agit pas de refuser tout ordre commun
mais de ne pas déléguer complètement les
questions d'éthique à l'état
il y a des choses qui sont dans les
règles mais qui ne sont pas morales pour
autant
mais alors pourquoi j'ai décidé
d'éloigner le plus possible de mon cerf
professionnel le juriste cerveau gauche
en effet ça pourrait être intéressant de
collaborer avec lui
et bien parce que ce sont des gens qui
seront enclins dans le respect de la loi
à faire des choses profondément
immorales si vous faites avoir pas le
cas par quelqu'un qui a la loi avec lui
vous ne pouvez rien faire ça m'est déjà
arrivé et encore plus si vous avez moins
de 18 ans
maintenant que je vous ai raconté mon
histoire revenons-en à la canne
vers l'été 2021 je fais ma première
canne une canne à système avec un pic à
glace dedans
enfin d’année le média néo prend contact
avec moi et réalise un reportage le
reportage a fait plus de 10 millions de
vues autant vous dire que c'est énorme
personne ne sait ce qui a fait que ça a
eu autant de succès toujours est-il que
ça complètement changé ma vie dans ce
reportage je ma première canne parmi mes
réalisations et c'est là que naît tout
un engouement autour de la canne je me
renseigne davantage sur cet objet j'en
fabrique d'autres je suis même allé en
Belgique rencontrer le dernier fabricant
de Cannes à la main pierre vannerk
c'est ainsi qu'on arrive aujourd'hui à
la avec la à la relation que j'ai avec
la canne que je fabrique que je vends et
que j'ai cette tant bien que mal de
remettre au Pinnacle
c'est très bien tout ça mais pour nous
dire pourquoi la canne et bien pour
trois raisons
primo la canne est une possibilité de
créativité infinie en effet si on prend
du recul qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une
canne c'est un objet d'au moins 80 cm
solide dans sa longueur c'est tout à
partir de là il y a deux impératifs à
allier caractère et grasse
à partir de là toutes les possibilités
de créativité sont infinies on peut
varier les matériaux les formes les
couleurs les bois on peut même mettre
des systèmes dedans comme un
tire-bouchon
secondo l'esprit d'un homme se devine à
la manière dont il tient sa canne c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est Balzac
la canne et le reflet de votre
personnalité par exemple tenir sa canne
par le milieu et la balancer signifie la
confiance en soi signifie qu'on est sûr
de soi la planter énergiquement comme ça
à chaque pas signifie que l'on est
contrarié et qu'on est énervé une prise
anarchique un peu comme ça signifie que
signifie la versatilité l'indécision
à l'heure où notre apparence pour le
meilleur et pour le pire dit tout de
nous et où le moindre accessoire compte
la canne à tout pour revenir à la mode
tercio je vais enfin vous dire pourquoi
la canne a disparu au début du 20e
siècle à l'apogée de la canne un
phénomène va tout bouleverser la
voitureisation à une époque où Paris se
développe déplacer à pied la voiture va
tout changer désormais on ne frime plus
avec une belle canne mais avec une belle
voiture de plus les injonctions de la
société industrielle ne nous permettent
plus de se déplacer avec la canne qui
nécessite une certaine oisiveté dans la
démarche
mais aujourd'hui alors où les gens se
déplacent à nouveau à pied surtout vu le
prix de l'essence
alors
à l'heure où le désir de bien s'apprêter
revient en force notamment chez les
jeunes à l'heure du dentisme la canne à
tout pour séduire la canne n'est pas
synonyme de vieillesse mais elle traduit
la maturité et l'assurance
aujourd'hui bien s'habiller embrasser la
beauté et créer de la beauté c'est
devenu si curieux et inconvenant que
c'est désormais un symbole de révolte
dans un monde aussi terne et maussade
c'est pourquoi j'ai le grand projet en
m'exerçant la sculpture de mettre des
pommeaux en forme de grand personnage en
bronze comme ça se faisait beaucoup
autrefois en mettant des bustes sur des
cannes je souhaite non seulement
permettre aux gens d'avoir accès à cette
beauté au quotidien mais en plus de
pouvoir la transporter avec eux pour la
montrer au monde c'est ça le plus
important
porter la canne à l'heure actuelle c'est
être adulte face au monde face à un
monde de plus en plus superficiel porter
une cravate porter un chapeau c'est une
révolte aujourd'hui le chapeau autrement
appelé le couvre-chef à vous de savoir
si vous voulez l'être le chef
alors je vous pose la question à chacun
d'entre vous qu'attendons-nous pour nous
révolter merci à tous
[Applaudissements]